there is perhaps no greater priority in
childhood than to acquire an education
it's in the early years that we have to
push ourselves with special vigor to
learn the lessons and acquire the
experience that's going to help us to
successfully maneuver around the
pitfalls of adult life by studying hard
and intelligently will have the best
chance of avoiding a middle-age of
confusion and resignation regret and
sorrow the clue to a successful adult
life were repeatedly told lies in
childhood education it's for this reason
that we send weary children out into the
world on dark winter mornings with full
rucksacks in order to spend the day
studying co-ordinate geometry and
indefinite articles the social impact of
religious and economic changes under
Edward the 6th and the place of
Aristotle's philosophy in Dante's
Inferno but there is one very striking
detail to note in our approach the one
subject that almost certainly has the
most to teach us in terms of its
capacity to help us skirt adult dangers
and guide us to fulfillment the subject
that far more than any other has the
decisive power to liberate us this
subject is not taught in any school or
college anywhere on the planet
a further irony is that this unstudied
subject is one that we nevertheless live
through every day of our early years
it's part of our palpable experience
unfolding all around us as invisible as
air and is hard to touch as time the
missing subject is of course our
childhood itself we can sum up its
importance like this our chances of
leading a fulfilled adult life depend
overwhelmingly on our knowledge of an
engagement with the nature of our own
childhoods because it is in this period
that the dominant share of our adult
identity is being molded and our
characteristic expectations and
responses set we will spend some twenty
five thousand hours in the company of
our parents
by the age of 18 a span which ends up
determining how we think of
relationships and of sex how we approach
work ambition and success what we think
of ourselves especially whether we can
like almost abhor who we are what we
should assume of strangers and friends
and how much happiness we believe we
deserve and could plausibly attain more
tragically and without anyone
necessarily having meant ill our
childhoods will have been to put it
nicely complicated the expectations that
we'll have formed in those years about
who we are what relationships can be
like and what the world might want to
give us will have been marked by a range
of what could be termed distortions
departures from reality and an ideal of
mental health and maturity something or
indeed many things will have gone
slightly wrong or developed in
questionable directions leaving us in
areas less than we might have been and
more scared and cowed than is practical
we may for example have picked up a
sense that being sexual was incompatible
with being a good person or that we had
to lie about our interests in order to
be loved we could have acquired an
impression that succeeding would incite
the rivalry of a parent or that we would
need always to be funny and
light-hearted so as to boy up a
depressive adult we adored but fearful
from our experiences we will then
acquire expectations or internal scripts
and patterns of behavior that we play
out unknowingly across adulthood certain
key people didn't take us seriously back
then now we tend to believe but don't
notice ourselves believing that no one
can we needed to try and fix an adult on
whom we depended now we're drawn but
don't realize we're drawn to rescuing
all those that we love we admired a
parent who didn't much care about us now
we repeatedly but unconsciously throw
ourselves at distant and indifferent
candidates one of the problems of our
childhoods is that they are usually
surrounded by a misleading implication
that they might have been sane what goes
on in the kitchen
in the car on holidays and in the
bedroom can seem beyond remark or
reflection for a long time we have
nothing to compare our life against it's
just reality in our eyes rather than a
very peculiar desperately harmful
version of it filled with unique slants
and outright dangers for many years it
can seem almost normal that Dad lies
slumped in his chair and quiet despair
that mum is often crying or that we've
been labeled the unworthy one it can
seem normal that every challenge is a
catastrophe or that every hope is
destroyed by cynicism there's nothing to
alert us to the oddity of a
seven-year-old having to cheer up a
parent because of the difficulties of
her relationship with the other parent
unfortunately the last thing that the
oddest parents will ever tell you is
that they're odd the most bizarre adults
are most heavily invested in thinking of
themselves and being known to others as
normal it's in the nature of madness to
strive very hard not to be thought about
this drift towards unthinking
normalization is compounded by
children's natural urge to think well of
their parents even at the cost of
looking after their own interest it's
always strangely preferable for a child
to think of themselves as unworthy and
deficient than to acknowledge their
parent as unstable and unfair the legacy
of a difficult childhood by which one
really means a typical childhood spreads
into every corner of adult life for
decades it can seem as though
unhappiness and grief must be the norm
it may take until a person is deep into
adulthood and might have messed up their
career substantially or gone through a
string of frustrating relationships that
they may become able to think about the
connection between what happened to them
in the past and how they are living as
grown-ups slowly they may see the debt
that their habit of trying to fix their
adult lovers owes to a dynamic with an
alcoholic mother or over many hours of
discussion they may realize that there
need be no conflict between being
successful and being a good person
contrary to what a disappointed father
had won
imputed the focus of present education
lies in understanding the outer world
the system tells us that we will finally
and optimally have succeeded when we
grasped the laws of the universe and the
history of humanity but in order
properly to thrive we will also need to
know something far closer to home
without a proper understanding of
childhood it won't matter how many
fortunes we've made how stellar our
reputation or outwardly cheerful our
families we will be doomed to founder on
the rocks of our own psychological
complexities we will probably be sunk by
anxiety a lack of trust
some kind of dread paranoia rage and
self-loathing those widespread legacies
of misunderstood childhoods well-meaning
people sometimes wander with
considerable hope if Sigmund Freud has
not after all by now been proved wrong
the tricky and humiliating answer is
that no he never actually will be in the
substance of his insight Freud's eternal
contribution has been to alert us to the
many ways in which adult emotional lives
sit on top of childhood experiences and
how we are made sick by not knowing our
own histories in a saner world we would
be left in no doubt and even partially
alerted while we were living through
them that our childhoods hold the
secrets to our identities we would know
that the one subject we meet to excel at
above all is one not yet flagged up by
the school system the subject called my
childhood and the sign that we have
graduated in this topic with honors is
when at last we can know and think non
defensively about how we are in small
ways enlarge a little bit mad and what
exactly in the distant past might have
made us so
our book what is psychotherapy tells us
exactly what going through therapy is
like and why it is so important to find
out more follow the link on your screen
now